welcome to this video round 11 of the
candidates and this video is about the
game too pal of kyle aachen um yeah um
tupelov is basically out of the race is
on minus to being last in the field
suddenly he had imagined something
better to to happen to him in this
tournament while kayaking on fifty
percent has some chances still on
because he's got a game against aren't
left so on he has got the chance to win
against aren't getting a point himself
and actually yeah making I heard lose
the game which seems tricky in this
tournament he's very solid so but in
addition to that he would also Ninon win
another game so let's see what happened
to em I was a bit critical of kayaking
in the last game as he simply didn't
continue to to play in a position which
still seem to have some life in it again
stunned Reagan ok but so let's see what
happened to him to Paula opened with
nida 3c four he is very flexible of
course also playing eform he's basically
playing all openings and here we um
transposed to an English opening
kayaking is playing c5 here because he
does not want to get into a Queen's
Indian position with the bishop on b7 he
placed the Queen's Indian for example if
we if we just for argument's sake put
this on the board here he placed the
line was Bishop to a 6 which is
considered to be quite okay for black in
the game tupolev uses this move order
with g3 and if now like em wants to go
for the same white is simply delaying
the move deform so now black needs to
commit with this bishop and there is
only we should be seven making some
sense now Bishop a6 does not make much
sense here without d for being played
and this way white a strict black into a
Queen's Indian that he does not want to
play it's not bad with the bishop on b7
but not k Atkins repertoire so he plays
c5 in this position transposing to a
symmetrical English here black can play
a six leading through the Hedgehog like
that for example or you can play the
move from g6 the double fianchetto um
which has a very solid reputation and
played by K arcania white is developing
and like please d 6 yeah the Queen
capture on d4 early is very typical in
this symmetrical structures of the head
shock and the double fianchetto because
why does not really want to play a quick
night to takes deform to exchange
bishops like is mostly helped by
exchanges because he's slightly cramped
you know it's on the on the sixth-ranked
now and white is on the fourth-ranked is
just more active and black likes to
exchange some pieces so greedy for is
designed to not allow too many exchanges
yeah d6 rook to d1 and night to d7 yeah
the knight c6 is playable it's not a
terrible move but normally you would
like to have your night on d7 this is
the more harmonious setup as it keeps
the bishop open and the white queen has
some decent squares anyway it's not
particularly great to put it on c6 97's
normal and now Bishop e3 yeah what white
really like to do is to play Queen to h4
and Bishop to h6 this would be quite
nice the only problem is if you go queen
edge for here black is going to play age
six and at the right point might even go
g5 and it's questionable what the queen
is doing there so why does first develop
in this bishop and only after some more
moves whoopsie eight rooks e1a 623 yeah
and now black is slowly but surely
running out of useful moves so he has to
castle and only then white switches over
with the Queen to get in not that to get
in Bishop age six to exchange the strong
bishop on g7 yeah kayaking now played
the move rook to c7 this is a funny
little move one idea of it is to play
Queen to a eight and this way increase
max influence on the long diagonal to
part of no place to move g-form yeah
this is a tough move to to explain to be
honest and I don't really know these
kind of structures of the double
fianchetto here so well because I simply
play a different set up against it i
play with an early b3 and bishop to be
too so I'm not so so well advised and in
this in destruction what I know is that
wider with his GF or push which is
played quite often um with this push he
wants to play obviously g5 and then
there is sometimes the idea to play
Bishop to h3 putting some pressure on
this diagonal um wyd of course also
could have played Bishop to h6 which was
the original idea but it somehow it's
not considered to be that dangerous it
seems it's not played that often g4
seems to be a the move that widest
setting his hopes upon and here ki can
place a very funny move I'm Luke c8 back
this looks completely crazy but I looked
it up he actually had played this move
before in a game in i think it was 2012
I need to check this 2012 yes is black
against the Dmitri yaakov Vancouver
strong russian GM the other idea is that
after possible g5 like the power of
plate this is actually a new move Bishop
h3 was played in the Yaak avantco game
after this a move like night d5 it's not
where the tempo on the rook this is
probably the explanation for moving the
rook back but yeah it's it's all
slightly strange here after 95 black is
not a technology seven so we actually
can do something else now but I'm not
quite sure what it should be a move like
a 6 i'm unsure about it looks like it's
weakening d6 quite considerably and I'm
not so sure what black smooth I see em
anyway can you play b5 may be here this
might be tricky as there's no night XD 7
threatened and black absolutely never
can take on d5 in the structure simply
because it opens up the c6 square this
would be simply a simply a very bad
setup with 96 and now now i'm unsure 95
is not completely ridiculous i think
yeah well 94 was plate and Ted this has
a completely different idea but not a
bad one note that the rook is going back
to c7 I mean that's really funny okay
here this was two polyps idea exchange
the h5 night and now Queen to a 8 this
was the idea of Luke c7 again but it's
all pretty it yet ok to pull off now
with 91 it's very difficult to make any
headway without allowing this exchange
blacks pressure on this long diagonals
already quite substantial and after 95
the part of plate
very funny move creature each one really
nice man look look at this symmetry on
the long diagonal and I learned that
there's actually a term for that which I
never heard before it I forgot who
coined the term it was a Dutch player a
Dodge player and the name he gave this
information was Reggie's rifle I really
like that it's a similar to al Atkins
gun this the squeem on the first rank
rook on the 7th awakens gun what an
allowance allowance I cannot pronounce
that correctly and this would be read
his rifle very nice from Richard rehti
obviously who was them was one of them
the become innovators 44 flank openings
in the 1920s mostly yeah very very funny
expression and yeah we we got traits on
the long diagonal no big surprise there
and yeah well how to assess this
position I actually thought that after
93 and the capture what we captured with
the pawn which are very much liked very
good move in my opinion strengthening
this poor information i actually believe
that white should have a slight
advantage here because of two factors
you have this pawn on d5 which is always
a bit of an annoyance as it keeps the
age porn on h7 and it also somewhat
hinders black skiing side I mean how do
you get the King into play white has
some easy ideas to activate the king or
maybe even to have three well black well
this is not really leading to much and
at the end that's h7 week so black
probably needs to get rid of the pawn
and TT played f6 very um yeah Barry M
quickly right now and do at this
exchange now so white has the slightly
better points
Jay's got one point Island to pawn
islands against three so it's structure
is somewhat better and there is b6 at
the point to attack note that black can
almost never play b5 as now I hear this
even now unless his even the sim
promoting now but this is the general
point where I can take a play a five
which leads to a complete complete
disaster here this even check a check
and a five and I think you're actually
promoting already you cannot cannot play
be five which is a slight problem as b6
is always under fire from the bishop
only three which is quite strong piece
so white has the slightly more
comfortable position here I think
however that kayaking did a very good
job in defending I mean it's not like
he's under huge pressure but why there's
always a bit more comfortable yeah
centralized the king which was also
allowed by playing f6 and then here
pushed with g5 which makes lots of sense
gained some space on the King side and
possibly even at some point can play h
form to get a passer on the edge file
look to h1 b 5 this securio smooth very
surprising from a positional point of
view as it puts a power pole on the dark
squares and even more so if we have this
none other than three potential power
pawns on on the wrong color complex the
complex of the bishop but it also has
some positive effects one positive
effect is that black maybe is able to
play rook f7 and get the bishop back
probably other way around you're not
blundering v6 and then you have some
counter play on the air valve on this
poll every query interesting strategical
strategic ID idea I keep saying
strategical but someone pointed out to
me that this is not
word yeah I agree it is not a word but
it sounds nice so I'm going to try to
use some strategic from now on all right
be five there are normal move one to fix
this weakness until I can play druke 2a8
here it seems he didn't want to play a
five putting in another porn on a dark
square but you can play okay it anyway
it makes sense maybe you get the chance
to open this up and actually use the
eighth on yourself yeah and a five this
is a typical two part of movies not the
kind of person who would sit on his
position and and try to do something
yeah those those those little moves slow
improvement he always wants to to break
through with possible and maybe it was
also an idea to put kayaking on the more
pressure with with him having limited
time to pull off as you can see I had
much more time on the clock kayaking was
down to about 10 minutes which is not a
real time trouble but still yeah a five
is some a pretty typical breakthrough
combination and supported by the bishop
of course yeah kayaking I took the porn
which is guess the only move on this is
probably maybe you can do that actually
is this so bad yeah probably it's not
it's not not really great what can even
take here yeah the other move is just
better i mean this is this one's for
sure takes and b6 this was to pollow's
IDM but in fact i believe it seems to
backfire after that it's only black with
some gaining some chances he piled up on
the b6 porn and now okay to play this
was the polyps idea in an ideal world he
would pick up both pawns and just win
the game but black in fact has a defense
IAM and it is
the capture of this pawn at first it
looks a bit strange because while there
is this why this is what's the part of
plate of course on yeah it is a big
pinion on b6 but black already has
gotten those pawns so he can always try
to give up material and use the a pawn
in fact here he could could have pushed
the a porn which would have been an
interesting alternative it however seems
to lead to a draw with with best plane
but still to pull off would have needed
to find that this also shows that this
operation with a 5 this breakthrough
operation is really backfiring because
even here black is able to basically
false ad wrong I can show you the
drawing if you if you want this is with
rook takes b6 all other moves leads to
some kind of trouble for what the
problem is simply the a porn running so
if white takes with the bishop just to
show it as a 3 and white um pretty much
has to play something like rugae to yeah
or maybe you can do it more precisely
like that this may be somewhat more
precise yeah and here you're just
suffering with a pawn down maybe you can
hold this position somehow but it's not
not something you would like to like to
try if there are better ways available
on what else is there a c5 you could
could also try but black can can take
this now and now give up the exchange
which is leading to a position quite
similar to the main game but it's in a
slightly worse slightly worse form the
move that draws is rook b6 and this is
with this line III and now why it is
just in time to stop the porn with the
bishop
and in fact it is really the case that
this pawn is is basically tying the
bishop to the defense of the a1 square
and black is also threatening to to get
a pass on the H file or break through
with G form and this basically means
that this Bishop is busy with the pond
and the same time you keep the White
King busy with the defense of the Kings
side it's a it's really a complete draw
if you give it to a computer it will
give you 0 0 0 i played through through
songs through some lines and it really
needs to leads to nothing so I'm not not
really a problem for like this line like
he could have done that but he decided
to take only 3 which is the better move
actually because it this actually gives
black chances to win the game the
ensuing endgame however is very very
complicated and I must admit that today
only have limited time and I'm not quite
sure if I really can give a definite
answer to to them about the evaluation
of the endgame I can show you some lines
of course but it's no not really
conclusive yeah okay White has taken on
b7 of course and now black played Bishop
c5 if we just take stock six pawns for
black form for white from a purely yeah
mathematical point of view black has two
points for the exchange but the main
thing is here that he is very nicely
coordinated the a porn is rather quick
can't possibly be supported by the
bishop on d4 for the promotion square on
a one and there's of course also the
play on them on the King side with the
age born and we get very quickly to a
critical position look to be 8 plate by
the part of a form look T 1
H form you really need to meet the age
porn yeah and to pile of not play
Jennifer first gets check okay then he
played the move G for not allowing
blacks King to to enter enter quickly
yeah and in exactly here there is a very
interesting suggestion made on on
Twitter on the social networks today
chesus is really busy you get lots of
interesting information I never was much
of a Twitter fan so now but in during
the candidates usually very often see
statements by strong players who who
evaluate positions give ideas and and
other interesting additions to the
information that you already have from
websites and other sources so here the
Dutch Grand Master Irvin Lummi pointed
out that a three could probably be
winning for black yeah it's a I went
through some lines but I'm not really
sure that I can conclude that black is
winning he certainly am and I think he
also wrote it and Twitter that he had
checked it with a calm everybody does
that nowadays um and he said okay he
believes this might win let's let's have
a look let's have a look I'll show you
some key ideas King see to this make
sense yeah you need the King to stop the
pond and now the key move is Bishop to
e3 this is doing many things it covers
the spawn and it prepares a further
break through public that we will see
soon um yeah what means now what you
move now I personally have looked at a
truck h8 white can basically just mark
time yet sir it's hard to do to do
something great for white um I was I
want to show you the key idea after
local jet it safe ephone this is the key
idea who black giving up the spawn
to enter with the king if we look at F
takes e4 for example there is king e5
and after Luke f8 for instance even King
deform so black is quickly activating
his forces and yeah evil wouldn't quite
a number of pawns and there's the edge
porn so this can be a be very very very
sharp and complicated I believe in
comparison if we go back here what could
also try the move rook e8 attacking the
a pond here also black is playing the
movie for this is the idea in all of the
lines to activate your king FTX king e5
rook f8 it basically always leads to
this position King deform just the same
it with Luke h8 King before and it's not
clear to me how wide should now try to
defend if we look at let's say hmm what
about look a five for example if we look
at that then this Bishop f4 and H point
will run okay this is not even playable
if you go King be three for example
black will take and something like that
it's too much there's Bishop f4 and then
I'm running with the H porn getting the
g porn as well so this is also not on
what should why do actually the computer
suggests 'if I've which is interesting
yeah that's an interesting move if the
King King now takes Jenn I'm getting
this check in which is very nice as this
is a checkmate and so black you would
need to return back to the sixth-ranked
probably black shouldn't take with the
king let's look at this if what happens
here
and now this caption yeah that's also
very tricky for what those pawns are
hard to keep can you give this check hmm
yeah it really looks very critical for
white very critical I mean how do you
actually stop the porn if I'm going
Bishop f4 nh3 without giving up
everything else IAM don't even see a
movie if well what about let's say I
play Waiting looks like that there is
this yeah yeah that's just very strong
always this FY dr now black will get all
the points and win with three pawns for
the exchange the cheap one is basically
meaningless can always take it with the
bishop yeah it's a very very dangerous
that'sthat's clear what i had looked at
briefly in the analysis before i started
the video is rook f3 i had this in my
notes into king of promoting Jack King
takes again looking very critical but
there is at least account to play that
white can try
now you can hear some mystics what did
it do I did something wrong yeah of
course black is not not not promoting
sorry I've looked at the wrong column I
need to take off course sorry and now
white is I'm going for this counter play
I believe c5 takes me five and see you
form a king a to c 3 and now i think y
term probably needs to look look for the
sea pawn rook f1 Bishop c5 to stop the e
porn a very long line change 1 C 2 and 6
mm SS winning for black
probably this is also winning King III
King be true king f3 tags I can try that
if I it's it's very a very funny stuff
that you can try here so maybe just take
it yeah and then white pushes him Jack
and not one hundred percent sure if this
really is a win i mean this line is by
far is now 20 moves deep from the a3
suggestion I mean black has serious
winning chances this is clear this is
really clear so maybe this is it so it's
certainly what you should have tried
that that's clear but if it's wins I'm
not so sure about I have mentioned with
limited time and had it had limited time
Bob preparing this is what he should
have tried but it didn't do he played
the bishop f 20 gauge 8 King g7 and here
it's probably over because the look is
always stopping the edge call while the
White King is looking at the a pawn in
the game they have made a couple of more
moves but it's a it is some somewhat
like a fortress and here draw a breed
not sure fortresses them right setup but
white is just always staying with this
king to guard against the aprons the
rook is guarding against the H Barnett
black cannot easily move the King over
because it would probably lose one of
the pawns or these pawns this the bishop
cannot at the same time God the G porn
and the a pond so it's really a pretty
much dead draw here yeah maybe kayaking
had a chance with a 3 i'm sorry that i
couldn't really get this to a conclusion
this was not possible but it looks very
dangerous my
gut instinct this should be a win for
black this move from a three that at the
ratio that I showed had shown him after
g4 here the push a three and not my move
but from from LA me llamas tweet that
would have been dangerous so very much
very much of a fighting and came here
between the two players and ya know win
for kayaking which was very badly badly
needed alright I hope you enjoyed the
coverage here maybe if you've got time
on your hands this is a very interesting
end game 2 to look at it's a very sharp
with many palm breakthroughs and andreas
situations so very much worthwhile to
analyze all right thanks for watching